like this altitude I can run flat out
for a half-mile before my hands start
shaking facility this episode is brought
to you by 99designs dot-com which is the
largest online marketplace for graphic
design with more than 850,000 registered
designers from all over the world who
compete for your business I've used them
for years and I've used them for some
very big projects like the book cover 4
before our body which went on to
becoming number one New York Times
bestseller
translated into at least I would say 10
15 20 languages and I used 99 designs
because I needed results and I needed
them very quickly so here's how it works
you need a logo a website book cover
t-shirt car app whatever you put a
description on 99designs comm then
people submit designs and in a week or
less you have an original design that
you love or you get 100% of your money
back
so check out 99 designs com forward
slash Tim you can see some of the
projects that I've done personally and
you can also get a $99 upgrade for free
this highlights your project listing it
with a prominent background bumping it
to the top of the page and on average
this will attract close to 200 percent
more designs so check out 99 designs
come forward slash Tim and I think
you'll like what you see this episode
has two amazing guests Tony Robbins and
Peter Diamandis we're gonna talk
principally about how to think big what
is involved in thinking big really 10
Xing 20 Xing what you're trying to do
and siphoning down the bios of these two
jets was very very challenging both of
them make me look like a real lazy
bastard who hasn't done anything with
his life which is inspiring to me so
there are different ways to take it but
let's get started Tony Robbins for those
of you don't know he's
I'm called a motivational speaker and I
think that's a total misnomer because he
is really a peak performance strategist
and his clientele is really astonishing
he has consulted or advised people
including Nelson Mandela Mikhail
Gorbachev Margaret Thatcher princess die
mother Teresa he's consulted members of
two royal families members of u.s.
Congress US Army US Marines three u.s.
presidents including Bill Clinton and
some of his other celebrity clients
include Serena Williams Andre Agassi
golf legend Greg Norman Leonardo
DiCaprio the list goes on and on and on
he's been named by Accenture one of the
top 50 business intellectuals in the
world by Harvard Business press is one
of the top 100 business gurus by
American Express one of the top six
business leaders in the world and and I
should say certainly last but not least
he is the creator of a product that many
of you may have seen around which is the
number-one personal and professional
development system of all time called
personal power I have quite a background
with this program and in a future
episode Tony and I'll be talking a lot
about it but personal power has sold
more than 40 million audio tapes and CD
copies worldwide he himself has also
developed and produced five
award-winning television infomercials
and here's the stat that might blow your
mind
they have been continuously aired on
average every 30 minutes 24 hours a day
somewhere in North America since April
1989 okay so for more than 20 years
I guess 25 years every 30 minutes 24
hours a day a Tony Robbins infomercials
pin on television in North America it's
amazing and that is just a small
fraction of his bio but I don't want to
cut Peter short Peter Diamandis or I
should say dr. Peter Diamandis has been
named one of the the world's 50 greatest
leaders by Fortune magazine in the world
of innovation
Dumanis is chairman and CEO of the
XPrize foundation best known for its 10
million-dollar Ansari XPrize for private
spaceflight the XPrize is really
intended to lead the world in designing
operating large-scale global
competitions to solve what Peter might
call market failures he's also the
co-founder and vice chairman of human
longevity Inc genomics and cell therapy
based diagnostic and therapeutic company
focused on extending the healthy human
lifespan it goes on he is the co-founder
and executive ersity I've actually spent
time there as adjunct faculty basically
in the entrepreneurship track this is
based at NASA Ames center
it's a graduate level Silicon Valley
institution studies exponentially
growing technologies their ability to
transform industries and solve
humanity's Grand Challenges Ray Kurzweil
some of you may know also very involved
with that and in the field of commercial
space Diamandis is the co-founder and
co-chairman of planetory planetory I
need more caffeine planetary resources a
company designing spacecraft check this
out to enable the detection and mining
of asteroids for precious materials
these two guys are amazing
I think you'll really enjoy this
conversation and often what holds us
back is not lack of resources it's not
lack of tools necessarily it's lack of
ambition we don't have dreams
aspirations that are big enough to
really catapult us to the next level of
thinking strategy operation and so on
execution for that matter so I want to
bring these two guys on and talk about
how on earth they got to be where they
are today in terms of just magnitude of
impact and and sheer sort of force of
will so I hope you enjoy it
without further ado please meet Tony and
Peter hello ladies and gentlemen this is
Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show I am
very excited to have two of my friends
on the line Peter Diamandis and Tony
Robbins gentlemen how are you great are
you I'm very well I know that you're
both very busy and I will want to dive
into quite a few different subjects so
right off the bat I think that the the
topic the general topics and I think
there are two intertwined that I'd love
to explore
in this conversation our number one I
think an aspect of your psychology is
that both are very well known for and
that is thinking big so I'm gonna dive
into that but how you started thinking
big and really big in many cases and
then secondly how you learn and how you
have learned and so I thought a very
perhaps tactical way to start off and
just jump into it would be asking you
each and maybe Peter we could start with
you what book or books you've gifted to
other people the most outside of your
own sure there's actually a few books
that have changed my world that I've
gifted the first is reading a spirit of
st. Louis by Lindbergh and you know the
setting is his story of this epic
adventure in 1927 of crossing the
Atlantic and doing it for $25,000 prize
and I was amazed at this man's
determination in the way he thought
about this and took the risk out and
then made this epic journey so that's
one I love Atlas Shrugged by Ayn Rand
it's something I've read multiple times
to sort of get me in the mindset of not
letting anything stand in my way and
really driven by passion what you know
is nothing is something that Tony knows
nothing about definitely kids sorry to
interrupt please continue no no then
there are two others that have been sort
of man who sold the moon which is a
science fiction book by Robert Heinlein
that talks about how this guy Dede
Harriman commercializes the moon and
it's just a brilliant 50 year old vision
that's as relevant today and then a book
by her my good friend Ray Kurzweil
called the singularities near which well
as the the basis for the foundation of
singularity University and it's funny
because all of these books each of them
in in turn were so purposeful to me they
they were the drivers for me starting
many of my companies awesome
no that's I'm going to go pick up all
this just as a side note for folks
Heinlein
for those of you who use the word grok
grok this grok that that is from
stranger in a strange land
also by Heinlein a lot of techies don't
realize the origins of that word Tony
I'd love to love to hear your your
selection well I was tens what people
really want over the years probably the
most common books I've recommended are
as a man thinketh by James Allen because
when you think about the quality of
people's lives it starts with what
meaning we give things to people can
have the same exact experience and one
person thinks it's over and one person
thinks the game has begun and that is
the difference that makes the difference
in the quality of people's lives it's
not what happens to them as we all know
and the other one which is along the
same theme that I've probably given out
as well I give and I think it's gets a
small book it's it's a book that people
can read over and over again and get
great value out of it but man's search
for meaning by Viktor Frankl to me is
just one of the great books ever written
because we all in our lives the one
thing that's in common for all human
beings regardless of your background or
your economic position good bad or
indifferent we're all gonna experience
extreme stress in our life at some point
everyone's gonna have to face the loss
of a loved one
everyone's got to face the loss of a job
or an opportunity or government change
in policy that affects your business or
some health issue yourself or a robbery
or the loss of your home the burglary
burning down I mean all these horrible
things in your lifetime you're gonna
experience and to be able to learn from
someone who experienced the Holocaust
directly who not only experienced the
Holocaust but walk through what was the
difference between those who made it and
those who didn't and most of us have
read the book no it wasn't the strongest
that survived it was those that had a
higher meaning for their pain those that
found a way to even take suffering and
transform it into a meaningful
experience you know most people today we
live in a society where people think
happiness is what life's about but you
get bored being happy some people you
know they're so damn happy they create a
problem just to have variety in their
life because we have lots of needs as
human beings and they make up problems
they don't even have i-ight doubles
extremely wealthy clients and you should
you know some people here they're
probably go yeah I'd love to have those
problems so meaning
what really matters and to to witness to
go through the experience in an
Associated way and see how this man not
only transformed his own life but then
came back to help so many others I think
is one of the more invaluable components
but another book would be the fourth
turning because I also believe you have
to understand that life is seasons and
the fourth turning is written by two
brilliant man who acted through an
original book that Jefferson Clinton
gave me when I went to them 20 years ago
called generations which goes who you
know a hundred years of Jeb's
generations and walks through how
basically we adapt to the way we've been
brought up and bring up our children
differently and how that creates gross
patterns that affect history but before
turning is just an incredibly in-depth
experience that shows you that human
beings go for periods of time 10 15 20
years usually from a 15 year range of
the stage we are now where we have a
primary set of emotions there are
winters where people will tend to find
what's wrong there's the springtime of
possibility there's a hot summer and of
course there's the fall where the
rewards are very very simple and you can
tie these to economics you can tie them
to emotions and it's just an
extraordinary book to put your life in
perspective and so you learn you know
some people freaked out in the winter
you know other people you know some
people freeze it up some people ski and
snowboard and how to take advantage of
whatever season of life you're in and
how to utilize that to anticipate in
your business in your life I find to be
unvalued well but it depends what
somebody's looking for I just
recommended slow sex to somebody
yesterday that's Nicole did Onan and the
other person I was watching them deal
with their kid and I said you got it
people pick up mindset by the Stanford
University because you're keep telling
your kid how perfect they are and you're
gonna run them because what they telling
a kid that they're perfect creates a
frame of reference where they have to be
a certain way as opposed to you know
giving them the feedback because they
put out the effort effort they can
control who you are is a whole different
component so I'm always honestly seeing
what's needed for that individual now
but if I'm going Universal I think it's
understanding the seasons of life it's
understanding creating meaning and it's
understanding how your thoughts are the
ultimate control of your life no I agree
and the I think for those people curious
to dig into also the parenting
aspect the event and you mentioned I
think that brain brain rules and the
author thinks name is professor Medina
out of U Washington also underscores
that as does Josh Waitzkin actually who
I interviewed on this podcast who was
the basis for searching for bobby
fisher' and he talked about the same
thing
how emphasizing sort of effort over
attributes this is and continues to be
increasingly important and raising
children the the DES was a sort of macro
level aspect of both of you that that
jumps out most immediately to a lot of
people it's just the sheer scale of what
you do and so Tony for instance I mean
how many how many people are you going
to be feeding or are you aiming to feed
and in 2015 three years Amy it's not
it's turned out with when I was 11
somebody fed my family I don't even know
who it was I just met the man at the
door who delivered the food and it
radically changed my life because it the
meaning I took out of it was at
strangers care if strangers cared about
my family then regardless if my father
told me I was going to care at a
different level it changed my entire
life so I said you know when I this
happened I was 11 when I'm 17 was the
first time I fed two families and then
for the next year then eight and then it
was getting a little tough so I got some
friends involved and then my companies
grew so now for the last you know thirty
seven years I fed forty two million
people but I feed about four million two
million people each year through my
foundation and I do two million myself I
do matching funds for the last five
years so but this year you know last
year I don't know if you saw but a lot
of people didn't even notice a Congress
cut food stamps by eight point two
billion dollars which is the equivalent
so you understand of the families are
supporting going without feed one week
out of the month just arbitrarily
without figuring out how to make up for
it and I obviously work pretty
passionately with all these nonprofits
cuz I help support them all and their
being maxed out and so I thought you
know what I'm writing this book right
now and finances and I'm fortunate to do
quite well
but if I took all the money of that and
I donated it you know how many meals
could I donate and that wasn't enough so
I said well I'll write a check above
that I thought if I could do as many
meals as I've done in my lifetime in a
year that'd be a good start so I said
you know okay
find 42 million meals holy [ __ ] that's a
large drink of water how about how about
I donate everything to the book and I
put up a big check and I feed 20 million
people this year and I get matching
donations but as I've gone along I've
gotten more inspired and I've partnered
with Fanta
feeding America which is the largest
domestic feeding organization the best
organization and I've negotiated with
them to cut out all of the costs and I'm
now I've raised my game I'm my total
number and I'm writing a check for in a
few weeks November 18th is 55 million
meals I'm personally gonna deliver 55
million people and then they're gonna
partner with me to get that - 100
million with matching funds so I know
for sure I'm gonna feed 55 million this
year Wow that's not my foundation or
they are the work that I do
looks like and these numbers to most
people are just almost unimaginable and
so that just this Peter just due to
perhaps catch people up on a couple of
examples of the work you've done with
the XPrize and of course you've done
many different things in addition to the
XPrize but what are what are some of the
problems that you're attempting or are
tackling or have tackled with with the
XPrize to date and I know we're gonna
certainly we all have sort of a secret
agenda to talk about one that we're
particularly passionate about right now
but what are some of the others that
dimension sure so people might know the
work we do here for the original Ansari
XPrize for Space Flight modeled after
Lindbergh's flight across the Atlantic
to win a $25,000 prize we put up ten
million dollars back in 1996 for the
first team to build a spaceship and
carry three adults up into space and
back and the the relevance here is that
individuals today can do extraordinary
things and you need to give them
guidance you know without a target
you'll miss it every time and and if you
incentivize them you can get
entrepreneurs from any place any walk of
life independent what they've done
before to do extraordinary things and I
fundamentally believe that so the
question is can you point entrepreneurs
at the world's biggest problems the
Grand Challenges and that's what we're
doing in it oceans and health and
learning and energy one of the prizes I
think that's relevant that we're in the
midst of right now is called the
Qualcomm tricorder X Prize so anybody
who's a fellow Trekkie knows from Star
Trek
you know dr. McCoy bones would have
this device called the tricorder he'd
pointed at somebody and be able to tell
if a bright Gillian fever or if they're
an alien or whatever the case might be
and it's sort of the the vision of where
we're going so we partnered with
Qualcomm Paul Jacobs who the chairman
there they put up 20 million dollars and
we have challenged teams around the
world to build a handheld mobile device
not for a doctor for a nurse it's for a
mom or dad at 2:00 in the morning when
their kid is sick this is a device you
can talk to it's got AI artificial
intelligence on the cloud you can
Koff on it it can do the RNA and DNA
analysis of the bacteria in your in your
sputum you do a blood prick into your
blood chemistry is it's meant to be able
to diagnose you independent of the
medical system which is so broken right
now and you know we had 300 teams enter
the competition we're down to the top 10
will have a winner in 15 months but you
know people starting up with doctors and
nurses out of business and the answer is
no we've got a problem right now there's
going to be we're gonna be short
something on the order of a hundred
thousand doctors in the US alone by 2020
and that's great compared to the rest of
the world you know Africa has got 25% of
the disease burden and 1.3 percent of
the health care workers we could not
scale building hospitals or or
physicians fast enough so can't we use
technology to touch the lives of a
billion people and so that's that's one
of them the Qualcomm tricorder X Prize
and you know I think about it is imagine
technology that a Masai warrior in the
middle of Kenya today has access to a
smartphone with Google they have access
to more knowledge and information than
President Clinton had 20 years ago and
they're paying a dollar a day this
democratization and this.d monetization
is where we're heading and I think what
I'd love to ask both of you and Peter
perhaps we could start with you is when
did you leave this very incremental
linear thinking because for a lot of
people they hear millions of dollars
tens of millions of dollars and they
they they immediately respond and their
own head with I could never do that
I could never raise that type of money
make that type of money have that
type of impact and when I interviewed
Peter Thiel on the podcast some people
may have heard it but he's obviously
known as a billionaire investor first
money into Facebook co-founder of
Palantir but back in the day he was on a
very traditional track to becoming a
lawyer and he ended up not getting a
clerk clerk lurking position and that
was sort of the redirection that sent
him into what would later become PayPal
and now of course he poses questions
like why don't you take your ten year
plan and ask yourself why can't I do
this in six months and it just it turns
out that sometimes you can actually
formulate a plan that works based on
asking better questions but you differ
for him there are a few moments that
really shook him or showed him that the
incremental approach was not the only
approach to Peter I'm curious at what
point did you develop this thinking or
who impacted you what were the triggers
that sort of led you to think this big
great question and it was probably so I
grew up passionate about space you know
watching the tail end of Apollo drinking
all the tanker got my hands on watching
Star Trek and it was driven by this
inner purpose and mission and passion
and I sort of it attached that to
becoming an astronaut and joining NASA
and that was my vision of my future and
as I got closer and closer to meeting
astronauts and meeting and seeing what
was really going on behind us I realized
that it was never gonna happen to the
government and honestly NASA had become
so risk adverse that it was massively
disappointing and it was this disconnect
between my vision of where the world
should be in the way it was and the way
was going and I had this moment in time
where I literally when I was at grad
school in MIT I did not submit my
astronaut application and I said screw
it I'm forget I'm gonna take I'm gonna
do this myself and I made a commitment
of myself to work to open up the private
space frontier on my own which is an
insane concept to think about well when
did you were you sitting having a cup of
coffee and just like looking
cross the cafe did some you know what
what was what was the moment when you
were like screw it I was I was in the
man vehicle lab at MIT I was doing
research on human physiology and I had a
bunch of shuttle astronauts in the lab
and I was talking to them Bayern
Lichtenberg and Owen Garriott and a
number of folks and I was listening to
their stories of how what they had to do
to get into NASA and how they had to be
a good boy and do what they were told
which is not me by any stretch no and
and and and then I was told you know
your chance Peaks like er 1,000 if you
get selected maybe you'll fly and if you
fly you might fly once or twice your
career I'm like holy [ __ ] that's
ridiculous I mean this is not my vision
of way opening up space is gonna be and
it was so antithetical and I had so much
energy and emotion tied to this desire
that I literally poured that all into a
brand new approach which became
zero-gravity corporation XPrize space
adventures planetary resources a whole
bunch of things we're just beginning and
and I just I think it is now possible
for an entrepreneur to do anything to
take on any grand challenge and and I
think it's it's an important message you
can stop complaining about problems and
start solving them that's what we're
living in today and is there just to
look at say the Ansari XPrize so it's 10
million dollars going from MIT to say
the first XPrize obviously there there
are a lot of of different steps in
between but someone I just I know it's
it this may seem like I'm beating a dead
horse on this like 10 million dollars
but it's such an unfathomable number for
a lot of people ya know I didn't have
ten million dollars right you're my
brother burn up st. Louis and my good
friend Greg Matt gives me and I hear
about hey if I can create a prize maybe
that's them that's the means I get my
ass into space right and so I start
noodling this as I'm reading the book
ten million bucks is enough money you
know I'm gonna call the XPrize
because I'd had no idea who's gonna put
up the 10 million bucks the ex was gonna
represent the name of the person who
would eventually put up the money I had
a variable to be replaced so long story
short I'm like scrambling for back then
you know 100 bucks here a thousand bucks
they're getting the seed money to get
this going and I end up in st. Louis
where an amazing man al Kurt says I will
help you raise some seed money and he
was driven and connected by my passion
my commitment to this and he helped me
raise about a half a million dollars in
10 and 20 K checks from the people and
people connect with your passion with
your heartfelt desire to do something
bigger than yourself and they're willing
to back that to some extent
long story short over the course of a
year and a lot of you know worn out knee
pads I raised enough raising a million
dollars and then we're fun raising
stalls and we make the very bold
decision that we're going to announce is
10 million dollar prize anyway there's
no money in place and we end up going
out under the arch in st. Louis and one
of the things I teach entrepreneurs in
fact I write about this in my my next
book called bold which is how you
announce a big bold idea to the world
really matters if you announce it below
a line of credibility we all have a line
of credibility around ideas we judge
them constantly if you announce it below
the line of credibility people dismiss
it out of hand and then we had this line
of super credibility that if you
announced it above the line of super
credibility people say wow when is it
gonna happen how can I be involved so
for me even though I didn't have ten
million dollars I didn't have any teams
I got on stage to stand by my side you
know twenty astronauts from Buzz Aldrin
and others the head of NASA the head of
FA who would seen me over many years and
it took a lot of convincing I mean this
is sort of the even getting to that
point was a pinnacle of years of work
but driven by this commitment so we
announced this prize front page around
the world and because I'm absolutely
positively sure I'm gonna raise the 10
million dollars who wouldn't want to pay
10 million after a prior after a person
did it right you it's paid only on
success challenges
150 CEOs later over the next five years
between 96 and 2001 everyone's turning
me down I finally meet the Ansari family
there's a lot more detail here but
listen the fact the matter is if I there
were many times at 3 a.m. in the morning
when I was tempted to give up and it was
only because I was being driven by my
internally my you know my own massively
transformative purpose that kept me
going and we're here today having this
conversation because I did not give up
so I'll leave it at uh no I love that
story and I think what's what's what I'd
love to underscore as much for myself as
anyone else is that you also had the
public accountability because you'd made
that I burned my ships dude yeah you
burnt your ships
so that's a wonderful story Tony I I
know a lot about your story and of
course we're gonna have a follow-up
conversation to talk about many other
things but I've read all your books
listened to a lot of your material and I
know that you weren't always the Tony
Robbins that people know of today I mean
there was a point where you were sort of
well there there's a lots of the story
of course but what were what were the
triggers for you the influences the
moments where you sort of decided ok
instead of helping and additional you
know feeding an additional two people
per year or making an additional 10k per
year or whatever it might be in those
sort of increments where you went to
really getting bold as as Peter might
say I think it's driven I think it
unfolds with time there are moments
along the way but they're inevitable
moments that come with growth and growth
only comes if there's something as Peter
said that you're passionate about that's
larger than yourself because it's very
easy to become satisfied you know with a
certain amount of money a certain amount
field it's certain amount of sex a
certain amount of comfort a certain
amount of anything but if you said to me
what is the difference in people's lives
and what's the difference chain Peter as
I love dearly and the average person
it's hunger it he's incredibly
intelligent man you know the other
states who he is and it's just pure
level of intelligence but you
truthfully I've seen people that have
one-tenth the intelligence accomplished
more because that hungers there my
hunger from the earliest day was like
pee up people up and I think it's
because I was surrounded by so much
suffering I mean I hate to see people
suffer I love to like people up and I
found early that would light people up
was answers answers that could change
the quality of life immediately where
they could suddenly shift their body and
their energy would change their body
would change they could lose twenty or
thirty pounds that they could change the
relationship and suddenly something was
dead was fully alive nor is passion
because I don't care who you are and
whether you make ten billion dollars and
I know because I get calls from these
people that it's not the game the game
is your body at your emotions at your
relationships if everything else in your
life is going great and there's an area
that isn't in an emperor the blade will
bite you because we're designed as human
beings to grow or die that's just how it
works spiritually mentally emotionally
so along the way I wanted answers for
myself to start with I was short I was
fat we were bi grew up in a very tough
environment I had four different fathers
we had no food no money those things
kind of trigger you and as a result I
didn't couldn't get answers in my
environment I didn't have access to
anybody so for me it was books so I'm
very passionate about the power of what
how self learning can transform anybody
especially the world we have today where
you have access to everything literally
at your fingertips on your phone
anywhere you go but I was 700 books in a
period I thought he read a book a day
that was my goal I took a speed reading
class but I didn't do that I read 7xl
for seven years
but I read everything I could on
physiology psychology emotion anything I
could make the difference in the quality
people's lives and then gradually what
happened was I started you know going
from books to being able to use net time
no extra time I want to listen to things
I started listening those hasty cassette
tapes that's all if I am and as I went
through the process I didn't found
myself at events and I went to an event
that changed my life was the first real
teacher was this man named Jim Rohn who
was a personal development teacher was a
three-hour event I sat in this room and
I watched this man who's just so Eliel
in three hours share with people
principals that I knew would change the
quality of my life or theirs and I
decided to go to work for him if I
thought this is what I want my life to
be about this guy's the best at what he
does I want to live this stuff and so I
went to work for him and the core
essence that I got from being around him
was the
your life is really comes down to your
capacity to add value that in life the
only thing that makes you feel fully
alive is growing and giving and that
evolved my language of it that's what I
pulled by being around him not so much
by what he said but we said that grab me
in those early days that started open my
world was now my mother wanted me to
become a truck driver there was this
truck masters driving school these to
advertise and she was obsessed that I
could make twenty four thousand dollars
a year which was twice as much as my
father if I just go to truck driving
school and then I'd have this open road
and I thought you know I don't could
drive that truck far enough fast enough
long enough to change the world that's
not going to change the world that's not
what my passion is and so I went through
civ that and I saw this man I walked out
of there and I said it's about adding
value he showed me that on all levels
including economics that if you found a
way to do more for others than anybody
else you would have the opportunity to
grow expand have impact be economically
free have the choices you want
the next big chunk was when I got
exposed because I was always looking for
new teachers to a man named John Bridger
tour taught neuro-linguistic programming
NLP and I watched this man take people
in minutes and create changes they've
been working on in decades and so I
think him obsessed there was nobody in
that community other than therapists in
those early days and I convinced him
that you know 1819 I guess he hurts all
the time to let me come sit in this
class because I was gonna put my ear to
the door anyway no matter what and I
took notes like crazy at the end of
class and then there was a day there
where this person he was out of the room
and this person started going through
this this phobic exposure and started
freaking out screaming and I've been in
a room with 70 people and they're all
therapists and nobody's doing anything
and so I just stood up and I just
grabbed this person and I just I I
wasn't gonna let him suffer and then
everything that I've learned consciously
and unconsciously came out and it was
like magic and you know 15 minutes later
it was gone John walked in the room
every was like did you see what this guy
did you know he's a phenom I know phenom
all he did was I cared so much I had so
much intensity for the issue it's like I
you know I don't know how to give I
didn't know how to give something out
mouth resuscitation I was in a place
with my father-in-law where he dropped
and I mean dropped and nothing but I've
learned made a difference and somewhere
in my head in milliseconds while he was
dying
turning gray my brain remembered having
seen some fun J Gupta talked about it's
not mouth to mouth it's press
compressions to get blood into the brain
where does your brain come up with that
it comes up because it's a tune to
answers when you become in an altered
state of state of passion a state of
commitment a state of must when when you
listen to Peter when you put themself in
line when you the way you take as you
said you take people and you burn the
boats and those moments the answers are
so then I started making that my modus
operandi I went on you know national
radio in Canada and I challenged
psychologists and psychiatrists after
had four days of training and I said I
don't know what your problem is I don't
care if you if you have uncontrollable
phobias see me I'll handle it literally
in one hour or less and you know then I
got challenged psychiatrist called me on
the phone and made my whole career by
saying you're a liar you're a
Charlotte's and people like you should
not be allowed on the radio and I said
sir
I said have you ever met me I said of
course not
I'd say you ever met my clients he said
of course not I said so are you a
scientist he's a lot a physician I said
are you a scientist I said good because
the scientists would ever make an
assumption what you're telling me is
what you're proposing is your hypothesis
so the hypothesis is that I'm a
charlatan liar so let's prove it I'm at
the Holiday Inn tomorrow night anyone
listening come bring me your worst
patient bring me somebody you've never
been able to cure I said I'm sure you've
got plenty of those and I entice this
guy to a point we had nowhere to go and
so he brought me this woman he treated
for seven years sort of snake phobia but
she dream about a snake in the middle
night wake up four or five times a night
treated for seven years and 15 minutes
later I wrapped a snake around her so
that became my modus operandi a results
and that's where I came up the idea of
coaching I said I'm not a motivator no
one's using the term it's all don't cut
up the beginning of an industry but my
idea of coaching was not gonna get a
certificate is you're paid for results
so I'm going say you pay me nothing I'll
do one session give me the most an
impossible task got to turn around
you're addicted to a drug you're smoking
a cigarette you're in this place and I
built it I went to the United States
Army they said give me a program I'll
take any training program you have I'll
cut the training time in half and
increase the competency you pay me
nothing you said you're crazy I said no
I'm expensive and negotiated I took a
four-day pistol shooting program and
turned a one day program qualified a
hundred percent of people when before
they'd only done 70 percent the colonel
wrote the general says the first
breakthrough since
or lawn and pistol shooting I never shot
it down before it was this driving force
then I started with athletes then also
them working with Princess Diana then
President Clinton oh by the way you're
absolutely right because he didn't have
an AOL account back yeah I remember I
first started working them I said
there's this new stuff called email I
got this thing called AOL they will talk
electronically cuz I've heard about that
so and it just grew to businesses and
individuals so every time you do
something and you think you've done your
best if you're growing him and being you
find out it's not your best there's a
new level when you get there there's the
new horizon if there is a passion to
serve something bigger than yourself and
if you're not limited it's your thinking
I believe the state people get in
signifies what capacity of their brain
they're gonna be able to utilize and
I'll become an expert in changing your
state changing the story that limits
that state and then then finding the
real strategies that work is I don't do
[ __ ] what state you're and if you're
running east looking for a sunset you're
screwed you've gotta have the right
strategy as well those three things I
think we're gonna do it for anybody
change your strategy change your story
change your state and you can pretty
much change anything and Tony the what
was the last name of the NLP teacher
that you mentioned bringer John Green
dirt one of co-founders got it and I
think the commonality at least one of
the commonalities if I'm trying to piece
together the patterns speaking to the
two of you is that you put your
reputations where your mouth was right
in both cases yeah in slightly different
approaches but I just get to be so amped
up my hands are like getting sweaty just
thinking about big stuff just listen to
you guys speaking of big things I want
to make sure that we have ample time to
cover something that we're we're all
very excited about and that is the the
Global Learning XPrize and perhaps Peter
you could chat about this before we jump
into it though I want to mention a
couple things to people number one first
and foremost very similar to Tony in
this in this respect I've I've been a
lifelong reader and autodidact I've had
many incredible teachers but I've I've
my most important teachers in many cases
have come from books they've come
indirectly through words on a page and I
I was actually going to be held back my
for kindergarten because I I didn't
learn to read and my teacher was
convinced I couldn't read which was not
the case what would what ended up being
the problem is that she never explained
why I should learn the alphabet and then
I got into first grade and mrs. Vince
key I still remember her she said Tim I
know you don't want to learn the
alphabet but if you learn the alphabet
you will be able to read books like well
why didn't somebody tell me this and so
mrs. Pinski to this day you know I ended
up being the valedictorian in my my
grade school because of her and she had
competitions so it's just to bring it
kind of full circle she had these little
paper racecars that we would make and
put them on a wall and there was a track
with the number of books read and there
was a competition to get to the end and
and I got to the end but like but maybe
a third of the way through the year and
then we had to sort of extend the the
race track but it was all due to that
passion she had for look for reading and
her ability to explain the benefits of
it so as a segue Peter maybe you could
tell us a bit about the the global
learning XPrize which I'm so excited
about yeah and thank you thank you Tim
so when they think about what are the
world's biggest problems the problems
that if we as society could fix would
really transform this planet I mean that
every mother and father and every person
watching should really care about
there's one that when you pull that
thread topples others and that's
creating a world of literacy there's a
billion illiterate people on the planet
two-thirds of them are women and 250
million of them are kids and they live
in the parts of the world that will
never build enough schools or teach
enough teachers and I'll tell you one
thing a population of people who are
illiterate are more peaceful more
prosperous and less populous in fact it
was Bill Gates has a great TED talk when
she talks about the fact that the you
know there's something you can do to
stop population growth rates and it's
make a population healthier and more
literate and you do that they you know
growth stops in fact growth goes
negative and it really is a key part of
our world
s'okay at XPrize we every year pull
together the smartest people on the
planet and say where
should be focusing our next XPrize we
call this thing vision earring Tony's
been a part of it Tim I would welcome
your participation in the future and we
have this debate and discussion with
those smartest and wealthiest people on
the planet and literacy learning became
the focal point so we set out to create
something we call the global learning
XPrize and here's the question can we
can we get entrepreneurs around the
planet to build a piece of software that
can operate on any any phablet any
tablet and take a child where there is
nothing no litter adults no schools
nothing and on their own take them to
basic reading writing and numeracy and
that's art and we fundamentally believe
it as possible got amazing support from
Nicholas Negroponte
create one laptop per child who he and
Matt Keller who's running this prize for
us actually didn't experiment they took
tablets into Ethiopia into villages that
were 100 miles from any schools any
anything and they dropped the tablets
off in a box and the kids opened the box
learned on their own how to turn on the
tablet how to use the apps and how to
start learning to sound out words the
problem they had was that the software
was so poor it limited them and so our
question is can we create what Neil
Stevenson a great author and science
fiction would call young ladies
illustrator primer from from diamond--
age can we create software that allows
kids to teach themselves that's our
challenge that's what the Global
Learning XPrize it about and I think
there's a couple of really important
aspects to this that I'd love to
underscore for people well first I'll
just I'll second the the Neil Stevenson
recommendation if you're going to start
with one I'm a huge fan of snow crash
crypto nomicon but coming back to the
your boldest mission yet I think is what
you called in an email that I received
yeah and there are three things I think
that the the I think it's worth talking
about the old way
and the challenges of trying to meet the
demands of say 250 million illiterate
children how many that at least based on
what I've read it looks like that would
take 1.6 million new teachers by 2015
needless to say doesn't seem like
there's any way that the the old way
would scale right and another thing I
want to sort of point out to folks is
that if you create a literate numeron
mother or particularly younger women
children you you tend to in many
countries create educated families so
there's there's sort of a false
multiplier effect by attacking this and
the other thing I'd love you to talk
about is that maybe maybe you could just
obviously comment on how people can get
involved but the the the fact that it's
not just using software to make people
literate but there's a time constraint
yeah so I think it's 18 months is that
right yeah yeah it was a friend
Elon Musk that challenged us to do it
faster and then we originally planned
it's 18 months so literally so the way
this prize is gonna work we announced it
at the United Nations General Assembly
if I can say Tony Tony is one of our
major benefactor is underwriting the
purse we raised 15 million dollars of
prize money for this and we announced
that the UN GA we at the social good
summit and at the Clinton Global
Initiative I the honor of closing out
CGI with President Clinton talking about
this and we expect there will be
hundreds if not thousands of teams
competing for this team from them from
anywhere can be a high school team it
can be a team out of Microsoft the team
out of Mumbai
it doesn't matter and you've got to
build a piece of software we're gonna
narrow it down from a thousand plus
teams down to a top five and those five
were going to deliver their software to
us and they're each going to win a
million dollars of capital right there
and that software has got to engage the
student because if they if it's not
exciting for them to use this software
they're gonna give up and put the tablet
down and it's done game over
it's gotta actually be you know
compelling enough and exciting enough
and understand that child's favorite
movie star
sports star color so it engages them
personalizes it in a way that makes them
want to learn and we're going to deliver
that software those five finalists are
going to be delivered to 5,000 kids in
sub-saharan Africa and on 5,000 tablets
and we're gonna measure over 18 months
where they go from zero to how far they
can go in terms of reading writing and
numeracy and we're going to crown a
winner has to meet a certain level
I'm won't go into detail now but the
cool thing about this prize unlike any
other XPrize the winning technology wins
or the winning software wins ten million
bucks that's great but we also get the
right to open source that software so
imagine if the best software on the
planet for teaching a child reading
writing and numeracy now became
available for free on every tablet and
every smartphone put out there there'll
be a billion handsets in Africa by 2016
I mean imagine if every one of them
became the type of compelling teaching
capability that a billionaire used or
teenager mabye used the same the same
way at Google was the same for Eric
Schmidt or for the poorest kid on the
planet it's extremely exciting and
obviously I want to direct people to a
few places where they can learn more but
I'd be curious Tony to hear from you you
there's so many places you could invest
your time and resources as I'm sure you
get asked to contribute to many many
many many different things why is this
why is this important to you and why
have you decided to take such a sort of
a large position in supporting it well
you know I look at the how do you create
the greatest impact on the quality
people's lives and if you listen to the
three of us in this conversation as a
sampling I believe that the thing that
affects that most is learning I mean we
are growing learning machines a person's
ability to learn to grow to solve
properties to be able to expand is what
develops the quality of life for any
human being that's what we need for and
it all starts in the world we live today
in order to access the resources and
writing arithmetic right numeracy those
three components as basic as the art as
boring as they sound to us they opened
the door for all three of us I mean your
story Tim about you know not on the
alphabet but okay but and then I could
read because you understood at some
level even them that reading would open
another universe as it did to me I
transported myself into other people's
lives i transported myself and to new
opportunities and new concepts new
solutions all three of us have done this
all three have got this benefit Elon
Musk has done that and I believe that
self learned self-directed learning is
the most important of all because what's
gonna happen in that environment is
people's individual passions that you
let them hack their own lives they're
gonna let them revamp especially in the
world we live today where let me think
about a ten years ago we had what 500
million people on the web it's hard to
even imagine we got two billion today
and since six years we're gonna 5
billion 3 billion people are gonna be
joining that system but be able to take
advantage of that system fully you've
got to be able to have these fundamental
skills so my whole thing has become a
learning machine we sure as hell can't
do that when you have such a large
population of our society and of our
world that doesn't even have the
opportunity to start with so I'll know
the children's inventiveness is
extraordinary what we're really doing
here is using tools and technology to
literally open up the world so no matter
where you live you know we're all lucky
I mean but you look at how our lives
have changed I'll give you another thing
that I believe a principle that's
proximity we change proximity when Peter
came up with this dream of his he put
himself in proximity with a different
type of person over and over and over
again shared his passionate story and
that proximity opened up opportunities
you know books for a way of getting
proximity when I didn't have physical
proximity of some of those solutions but
that proximity for someone in South
Africa somebody in certain parts of
India some parts in parts of the
third-world to have there being no
separation from your capacity you have
the same education that somebody has at
MIT that somebody has at Stanford that
stuff is coming online but it's
worthless if you don't have the basic
code that alphabet you talked about in
the very beginning so I've put my time
my energy and my money on the line in
this area because I don't think there's
a more important we can gift back to
society I don't think another reason
when you look at society and you see the
problems that we have a lot of people
think of these problems as somebody
else's problems these are our problems
because if you look at the biggest
challenges in the world they come from
the people in society they're forgotten
they come from people that become so
frustrated they don't have a way to come
up with an empower meaning they don't
have a way to transport them something
another way to change the quality of
their life and those are the individuals
that turn to violence you know you think
about it somebody asked me a few years
ago I was in India and I literally left
the hotel there in India I think about
two days before the big bombing and I'm
loose on the bombing two days after I've
been there and I was talking with a
friend and they were with a group of
people one of the person was just saying
how is this possible how is this type of
violence possible how could somebody
kill men women and children in this way
and I said you know but it's really
possible because I'll tell you what's
not possible for it wasn't a happy
person it wasn't a growing person it
wasn't a fulfilled human being a happy
person's not trying to destroy somebody
else's life and if you want to know what
makes human beings happy it isn't money
money will give you a certain level of
happiness to pay which study you read it
is one thing one thing only progress
progress equals happiness if you feel
like you're growing expanding psychology
and your humanity and your emotion and
your capacity in your economics you feel
alive we blow we die and you put a giant
limitation on that based on where you
live in the world where you're born
unless you have access to certain
resources and the most fundamental
resource is learning but with technology
now it doesn't matter where you live if
you know how to learn the world is yours
and so on a zero to ten to me this is a
1 million of importance and that's why
I've committed the time energy capital
to help make it work and that's why all
the other people are doing the same
they're a part of this team absolutely
no it's well said and I I want to point
out something else also to those techies
listening cuz I know a lot of lot of
techies out there listening this and
even those who are not necessarily
technically trained I am NOT would find
the fact that open sort the the there's
an aspect of open source that we didn't
really touch on and that is not only is
it freely available to people to use in
some way and some interpretation and
some like a user interface but people
kit is then available to be improved
upon so I think it's it's very
fascinating that the list
say hypothetically we have these teams
five teams are given a million each they
bust their asses think big create really
innovative software to try to solve this
problem
finally a fund you find a winner the
code is made available people are
becoming literate who can then improve
upon the software itself it's just a
very sort of virtuous recursive aspect
of the whole thing that is really really
really cool and so guys everyone
listening and those of you who followed
me for a while know that I don't get
this excited about a lot of things but
I've been waiting to pick this shot for
a long time and I've talked about my
passion for education and and reforming
education improving education which is
really improving learning since my
that's right my TED talk 2008 and there
have been very few opportunities to
really use an Archimedes lever to to
sort of move the world and I think this
is this is very legitimately one of them
so Peter maybe you could well there are
two things the first is as we know based
on the results the spectacular results
of the XPrize that people respond to
incentives and that's not being good or
bad as being human people respond to
incentives so we have obviously for
those people who are interested in
trying to develop this software and
compete for the prize where should they
where should they go where can they
learn more yeah if you go to just XPrize
org our website you can click on the
learning XPrize there and there's
information about how to register as a
team how to pre-register right now and
it's pretty easy just tell us you're
interested in forming a team and get
involved we'll take you through the
process you know if you're a commercial
company great if you're a non-profit or
a startup whatever I know that when we
give people a very clear target it
drives them and focuses them and it's a
great thing whether you enter the
competition the final result or not so
XPrize that August how you can register
excellent and I should just mention to
people you know I had a conversation
with a good friend of mine recently
who's made
hundreds of millions of dollars and he's
a very grounded deep soulful guy and we
went for a hike because I've been trying
to decide on sort of about my next
chapters so to speak the next projects
that I pick and the way he encouraged me
to think about it yeah he gave me a
couple of questions to ask myself and
one of them was you know if your goal
were to be remembered in the history
books
you know metaphorically to 300 years
from now what could you do and you sort
of engineer it in Reverse from that
question you know if your goal is to
have a big impact let's get very
specific if you're gonna be remembered
two or three hundred years from now or
more what could you do and I would
actually pose that to people listening
to this and I would say one of the
answers is winning this competition I
really feel like it could have that
great an impact I mean you could really
go down in history for this one so
that's point number one point number two
for those people who just want to
perhaps look at some very very
fascinating prizes if you'd like to
support the global learning XPrize
there's an IndieGoGo page so you can go
to indiegogo.com and just search XPrize
no - needed and the first thing that
will pop up and I'll also include this
link in the show notes for people in the
global learning exercise but there are a
couple of prizes there there prizes for
every price point all the way from
twenty five dollars or ten dollars even
up but Peter maybe you could comment on
I thought you could maybe you could
elaborate on one of them which is the
the 10th anniversary and sorry
experts ticket well actually if I could
let me give context of why this is
important because it's really it's
really critical for people to realize we
do have amazing people like Tony Robbins
who I love dearly who was put up a
million dollars here we raised the
capital and you can see why would my ten
dollars or twenty-five dollars even make
a difference here and why should I
support this and let me tell you why as
an organization we have been dependent
on a lot of extraordinary
philanthropists I want to change that I
really want the XPrize to become an
organization where the public decides
what the biggest problems in the world
that need to be solved are
and then vote on those and capitalize
those prizes and literally create the
future it's like we want to solve this
problem
great we'll crowdsource the rules we
will raise the capital and we'll saw
that promise literally creating the
future it's it's throw yourself a
touchdown pass and this IndieGoGo
campaign is a is a means for me to prove
to the XPrize board into the world that
the crowd wants to be involved in
helping to capitalize these prizes and
cares about this model for solving Grand
Challenges so it's not about - half a
million dollars and a million dollars
we'll make you know donate ten bucks I'm
happy with that
but get involved because we want to open
this up so that it's really the world
solving its own problem stopping
complaining about problems are starting
solving problems that mindset is so
critically important for society today
the the second thing is where we're
gonna use this money that we raise so we
today are basically taking these the
software these tablets out to 5,000 kids
in sub-saharan Africa our goal is to
double that number and in success will
go to 10,000 kids not in a hundred
villages but 200 villages to really
statistically get the numbers working
best if you really see the major impact
of this global learning XPrize can have
and so how can you be involved lots of
ways you know like you said Tim it's
from 10 bucks up to 10,000 bucks I two
of my favorite if I could is is one of
them is for four for 25 bucks you can
get actually access to the winning
software for your kid or your niece or
your friend 18 months before it goes
open-source so we're gonna be actually
taking the five finalists and making
that those finalists available to
backers of this so if you want to play
with the software yourself 25 bucks
means you care about this prize and
we'll give you a download code when the
software is going out to kids in Africa
you'll get a chance to download it too
and they don't have to be technical in
order to use it no it's going to be an
Android app you download and and use
pretty instantly it's you in fact you
have to be as technical as the as
eight-year-olds in Africa that were that
were that we're working with and then
another very cool one if I could is at
at fifty bucks you get to be involved
envision earring you know vision earring
is this thing that we do 140 people CEOs
top philanthropists you can become a
digital visionary you get to vote on
which XPrize we should focus on next
year so you get to help direct where the
XPrize what Grand Challenge on the
planet we're working towards the next
you care about climate do you care about
water health what is it you get involved
so this is about really inclusion and
that's really why I want people involved
here show you care get involved help us
really change the world on a massive
scale
definitely and you know for those of you
who what we're interested in in really
doubling down in other ways you can also
you have a chance to spend some time
with with people with Peter himself Sir
Richard Branson and others at the 10th
anniversary Ansari X PRIZE event and
then also maybe Tony could talk a little
bit about date with destiny so this is
an opportunity to spend some time with
with Tony himself and that is also an
option on the on the indiegogo page but
perhaps Tony you could mention just a
little bit about that there we go
once a year the six day process it's my
most intensive program and you know
people from sports entertainment
business average people we have people
usually from usually about 40 to 50
countries we translate six or seven
languages and the outcome of those six
days is most of us don't understand that
there is a software program if you will
an operating system that really controls
how you think feel and experience every
part of your life we know about
generally we know we value know we
believe generally but we take that down
to a level that's my mind boggling well
you will understand why you think the
thought you think feel the feelings you
have and more
importantly once you understand what's
really the controlling force in your
entire life you rewire it because you
can't change something you're unaware of
and then you just have a random life and
I don't care some people have had
randomness that's brought a lot of
greatness to their life so you find
what's great in your life if I know
what's not and you find out the real
source and cause of it and it's an
experience that is I mean you laugh more
you cry more you're entertained and
level because it's raw and real and you
see changes that are unbelievable you'll
see a you know a guy that's just come
back you know the last thing we did from
Afghanistan whose shell-shocked who you
know as PTSD can't sleep at night it's
got the shivers when he you know tries
to hold the microphone his hand is
shaking out of control he just stands up
you never know who's gonna stand up and
you know you see him 45 minutes later
and he's not shaking you no longer
literally take his glasses off there's a
physiological change in him where he can
have light sensitivity and I brought him
on CNN to give you an example just show
people what's possible you see a young
woman whose face has been disfigured and
thinks her life is horrific and
literally there is a transformation
Hirsch you know we saw her about six
months ago and she's got a relationship
for the first time I like you see a
person that has made more money than God
who's achieved more they ever have it
they're bored out of their mind and
frustrated with their life and you find
out that guess what you know that
solutions not the solution and you see
what they're transformed like afterwards
and and you participate in these
processes so it's just the most
intensive individual program that I do
and instead of doing it with five or ten
thousand people it's the most intimate
thing idea where you'd do it with about
1,800 2,000 people and you get to
develop family with people and friends
from all over the world so it's the
ultimate if you want to transform you
want to learn what controls and shapes
your life the ultimate that experience
and should I know what is your in you
donated 10 seats at the 10k level and
that's actually being matched with
another 10k so if you donated 10,000 you
get to come today with destiny and Tony
you said you'll you'll take a photo and
spend a few moments with those
individuals which your time is the most
precious thing and and I can say that
having done date with destiny myself
with you I learned more in six days I
learned in four years at MIT it's the
most extraordinary experience of my life
I love you dearly buddy I love you too
pal so guys I know you you have worlds
to conquer out there and the global
learning XPrize is is really something
that has reinvigorated me and in a way
that has kind of been a long time coming
for me I feel and I I'm I really feel
like for those of you listening who are
in any way passionate about education
and you've been wondering how to pick
your shot how to throw that that one
touchdown pass I really feel like this
is a an excellent place and it's very
time-sensitive to focus your energy and
I'm going to be obviously getting behind
it as I am and doing some things to help
move the needle and you can go to X
PRIZE org if you want to compete plenty
of money on the line and glory lasts
forever right so so that's one and then
if you want to check out the IndieGoGo
campaign I will put the link in the show
notes so you can just go to the blog for
our blog comm and click on podcasting to
find the show notes or you can just go
to IndieGoGo comm and search for X price
without a hyphen before we take off do
you gentlemen have any any parting
comments advice recommendations rest of
my restaurant
tips anything at all they leave with us
before we get something because you see
the a combination in all three of listen
I see it I think you see it anybody
that's enjoying their life you know it's
the game never ends I mean life is a
game of mastery it's about finding a way
to do something and do it so well that
goes beyond yourself that if you can
find your passion if you find anything
you're passionate about it you don't
know what it is I think it's getting
around people that are really passionate
getting around where it's better and
letting something hit you you can't get
around a person like yourself or like
Peter and not be touched or something
inside of you is gonna get ignited so if
you don't have that passion yet you're
listening you know listening these
podcast is the way to get some of that
proximity but I'd go pursue putting
myself in an environment where you're
gonna be stimulated if you know what
your passion is then the question is how
can you surround yourself with the best
of the best that you can be challenged
because the idea of on the XPrize really
is it's not just the incentives it's
also the challenge it's that competition
to say
can I do more in less time for more
people than I've ever done in my life
and when that becomes your focus
something happens the vibratory rate of
the human brain and insights come you
start seeing things the reticular
activating system of the brain starts
finding answers because you have that
focus on something larger so if you
don't have it find it and if you don't
know how to find it get yourself in
environments consistently where people
are living it and something will hit you
Wow absolutely and that's that's that's
part of the reason that you know people
ask me why I live in Silicon Valley if I
could live anywhere and that's it's it's
not the tackett's that it's being around
the people who believe that they're good
conversation world absolutely Peter yeah
I mean it all begins with passion
there's no better teacher mentor on the
planet than 20 Robbins when it comes
down to that for me I'll just add on top
of that that there is no problem we
cannot take on you know the world's
biggest problems are the world's biggest
business opportunities I mean which is
amazing to think about you know you want
to become a billionaire help a billion
people that convergence and the notion
that a single individual today I don't
care who you are in the world where you
are in the world you have access to
extraordinary capabilities you have
access to you know the world's knowledge
and information on Google you have
access to AI to cloud printing all these
exponential technologies and at the same
time you've got access to all the
expertise you want through crowdsourcing
you have capital through crowdfunding so
my goal here is to say you know first
and foremost connect with your passion
let that drive that with you and then
take your moonshot where are you gonna
take and do something significant that
gives meaning I love that example you
you give Tim about how you give me
remembered you know two three hundred
years from today so it's an amazing time
to be alive it's an amazing time to be
an entrepreneur I am thankful Tim for
who you are in the world and Tony and
and blessed to be on this conversation
with you guys well gentlemen thank you
so much for taking the time would be
really fun to get together in person at
some point I know we're on different
coasts and constantly flying but the
this virtual proximity will do for now
and
everybody check out the XPrize it is it
is very worthwhile and there are plenty
of incentives for every player in the
game and if you're looking for that
passion that that Peter mentioned you
don't know what that passion is as Tony
mentioned one of the best ways to get
passionate is to be surrounded by people
who are very passionate and thinking
magnitudes of order above the the
average Joe or Jane you may be
surrounded by and a great way to do that
honestly is just to check out even the
page that describes this XPrize on
XPrize org or on IndieGoGo and you might
just find that as is the case with me
it's it's just it's per its provided
some some intellectual gasoline and some
passion that that you might not have
seen in a while so I think that it's
it's worth checking out and I'll be
doing a lot more related to it so guys
for the time being thanks so much for
being on thanks David thanks Peter
bye thank you for supporting the
sponsors of this show I've used them I
like them and I think you will too
99designs comm forward-slash Tim it's
the world's largest marketplace of
graphic designers you can see the
projects that I've put up the
competitions that I've spearheaded
including the book cover of the 4-hour
body and you can also get a $99 upgrade
for free so check it out at 99 designs
dot-com forward slash Tim of course you
can subscribe to this show on iTunes you
can also find every other episode and
the show notes links from this episode
at for our blog.com that's fo u Rho u r
VL og calm and just click on podcast
there's all sorts of other cool stuff
including my interactions with people
like Warren Buffett Mike snowed up
Linkin Park the list goes on and on and
on and I would love your feedback let me
know what you thought of this show who
you'd like to hear on the show next and
any other thoughts really you can find
me at twitter @ @ t ferrus that's
twitter.com /t fer Riss and on facebook
at facebook.com/ forward
Tim Ferriss with two hours and two S's
until next time thank you for listening